why did you decide to detransition was
there something that happened
um I don't know that much about gender
dysphoria to tell you the truth I don't
either
nobody does that's what I'm trying to
say is nobody does if we knew what
gender identity disorder was we wouldn't
be doing surgery on kids
[Music]
Chris back welcome to my podcast I'm
glad to have you on here
thank you
uh can we start off by you giving a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do and a little bit about
what you've been through
okay well my name is Chris back I'm
known as a Navy SEAL we're actually
originally I was known as a Navy SEAL
and that was about it and then after I
retired in 2011 I was uh I started
feeling things that made me want to
change my life a bit and then in 2013 uh
14 time frame I came out as transgender
and then uh and I lived that way for you
know quite a while and I say I lived
that way as a past tense which isn't
really proper because I think that's the
misconception a lot of people uh don't
know is that transgender is it's not
transgenders gender identity disorder
and uh that's something that I had and I
think a lot of folks have it except that
mine was possibly a little bit extreme
because of whatever reasons and then I
also uh I was retired and I was at that
point in my life where I was like I
don't care anymore you know and then I
uh I came out as Kristin and they made a
movie on CNN about it and then and then
everything just went off the hook after
that I went on a lot of news programs
and uh all kinds of things started
happening it was like the floodgates
opened up as soon as you go on one
episode it just it just goes wild and uh
and now in you know this year I
announced publicly that was
detransitioning and I was already
and I don't did word detransition I'd
love to talk about that also because
that's just a ridiculous word but um I I
started trying to go back to who I
really was I try to I try to figure out
what was wrong and I had to do this all
on my own because I had no help doing
this I asked for psychological help you
know in different ways and I almost felt
like the psychological Community is is
like a is on a track and I don't
understand it and so anything that was
wrong with me they would just keep going
back to transgender or saying something
about identity and all this stuff and so
that's when I started really digging
into like Carl Young and a whole bunch
of other books and and Jordan Peterson
as a matter of fact I didn't know you
were his daughter when I first said yes
to your podcast but yeah that's cool I
just well that's a whole other story I
don't so I just
I feel that I had to do it on my own
because I didn't have any help because
it seemed like it was such it was
propaganda the problem I see right now
is and it's the same problem we have
with everything in life it becomes
political it becomes binary it becomes
well actually binary is not that
different deal when you're talking about
people but that's another little joke in
there but the uh the it's a I would just
say hi Galen dialectic you know it's
like they always want us to fight they
want us to be in this camp and that camp
if you're in the middle they get mad at
you and then they try to force you on
one end of the other and I've always had
a problem with that because I'm very
much in the middle I'm extremely
conservative on some points I'm
extremely liberal on other points and
that's I think most people are like that
but I got pushed into these camps and I
was like I don't want to be in those
camps and so I started going towards the
middle and then both sides hate me and
then I'm like well I don't I'd rather be
hated by both sides and be myself and be
real you know be truthfully me which is
very much in the middle I'm not
Christian I'm not Christopher I'm call
me Chief you know because then you're
getting rid of all that baggage that I
had before and all that baggage I had
after and all I'm saying is my potential
you know look at me for what what I am
and who I am not by labels or Not by the
clothing I wear you know don't judge me
on my fashion because my fashion senses
it's flannel shirts if you look at what
I've done almost every interview and
it's the same flannel I own like three
of them and I'll never wear anything
else on an interview and I'm actually
thinking about dying them all black
because the same shirts which is dying
black like Johnny Cash because I'm so
tired of all this I just I'm waiting for
something to just it's gonna blow up and
that's the part that people do not
understand is that they're lighting
fires everywhere on both sides of the
aisle so you have the right light and
fires on the left and the left light and
fires on the right and you don't think
that's affecting people so they're
taking all of these issues and are
making them political and they're making
them egotistical they're making them in
the money and money's the biggest
problem but I mean I could go into stuff
for you forever but I want you to know
like my stance and where I am I had
gender dysphoria and and I think
generators for you is something that if
you're a transgender you all have
janitors for you you don't have
transgender transgender is like the end
result of the high I love all genders
for you is the gender identity disorder
and it's something that you can work
with now for me most of the life I was I
was between and I'm gonna do a 100 scale
I was like maybe a 10 I was like 15 I
was a 20. sometimes when I was like
anxiety or I was stressed out or
whatever I might be like a 20 with
identity going you know there's
something going on but then when I
retired it was pegging way up there I
was like maybe 60 because I was just fed
up with everything and I also went
through a lot too in my life it just
made me
start hating myself which is kind of
what all of the universities seem to be
teaching really well these days is how
to hate each other and which I quit
school I was doing my Master's in metal
uh and mental health counseling and I
100 quit school over a philosophical
argument with a teacher they're teaching
CRT this professor and uh Professor
started out as a third grade teacher and
now as a professor in college and it was
still third grade levels crap they're
teaching this hatred against the entire
white race every time she would say
anything about white people it was like
white people and it was like and it was
like yeah but I'm white and I don't I
don't hate myself I do sometimes I mean
I do dumb stuff don't we all you know
yeah I'm not I don't generally hate
myself I don't hate white people I don't
hate black people I don't hate Asian
people I don't hate anybody you know
flat out that's ridiculous who in this
world I don't I doubt anyone truly hates
everyone from an entire sect of people
you know down and hate a label or hate
something that I'm born with I hate you
because you have brown eyes why because
you have blue eyes it's the same thing
you know I'm born how I am and you're
gonna hate me because I was born come on
but that's what they're teaching
universities so when they started really
hammering it I wrote a paper I was
opinion paper and my opinion is my
opinion and if you say it's an opinion
paper how are you gonna grade me and
give me a 50 of 100 for my opinion yeah
it was a punishment because I challenged
the professor because I said this is
wrong I started bringing up and I talked
about this on another podcast a little
while ago it was like Great Zimbabwe and
all the kings and queens of Africa and
these greatness that happened throughout
the centuries on this continent and the
birth you know the creator of
civilization and I could go on and on
and on and this is stuff that I was
writing my paper saying that there's no
reason for you know people to hate each
other look how great the greatness and
we've had greatness and everybody's had
greatness plus we've had failures and
we've had mess-ups you know we've done
stuff wrong as Nations as peoples every
people's done stuff wrong so if you want
to start hating people then hate all
people you can't just pick one group of
people that in history did one thing and
what slavery in America was like 70 or
80 years total if you really look at the
numbers when we were done 1776 and when
it was when it was over it was barely a
blink of an eye and and all of Mankind's
history
kind of stuff really bothers me you know
but that's why I quit college when I
started seeing this this hatred against
people I started seeing the same thing
in the trans Community about the labels
and about hatred and about setting these
labels up for failure and I don't want
to hate myself and and so I started
looking at all of this and I put this
entire ideology into the same group of
CRT that did purposely separating people
for whatever reasons and causing
discontent causing Hate by labels by
mental health issues that are
exacerbated into surgery which we don't
do for anorexia or any other you know
thing that's bodily issued you know
Eating Disorders I don't see you doing
teenagers uh surgeries for somebody has
a eating disorder you know and then I
can go through this forever but so
that's I mean that's a huge explanation
of me but um you just have to understand
that all of this happened I would have
been silent I was already out of
transgender 100 a while ago and I
understood it started to for me it was
gender identity disorder was a mental
health issue which I can deal with you
know I can work on that but if it's
something you tell me that's permanent
that's something that we're all born
like this or I'll do this and there's
only one way to fix it well that's bunk
you know because you're putting a
blanket uh a blanket
um Solution on every human being that
shows up saying anything about being a
tomboy or hey I like to wear you know
freely and soft things sometimes it
makes me comfortable oh you're
transgender it's like come on you know
the whole thing has just been blown out
of the water so far that I just I had to
start speaking out I wanted to be silent
I never wanted to come on these programs
I I did that one with Robbie Starbuck
which you know great people and they did
a good job and then I went on Tucker
Carlson for like four minutes and it was
the only like mainstream I've done I
will not do any mainstream every time I
come on these kind of podcasts because I
looked at a little bit of stuff and I
actually looked up the wrong person
first but I looked stuff up and I see if
somebody's a good person and if they're
pretty good information and then I say
yeah I'll go on your show but it's
mainstream media I just keep saying no
not doing it you know unless you just
give me my my ability to speak and don't
interrupt me and talker was kind enough
that he did that if you look at the
Tucker Carlson um a show that I did a
week ago he just lets me talk and then
when I finish he says wow good point and
then he goes on to his next thing so he
was very respectful for that way they
let me speak and the message that I was
trying to give on talker was
raw people we all struggle the main
message is we all struggle you know we
all have issues and I have my issues and
you have your issues in everyone so why
would you want to pile on top of
somebody else's issues or why would you
want to take your issues and and shove
them on top of somebody else to make
their issues even even tougher and and
mess with their life you know and so I'm
saying that to all those folks on both
sides of the aisle that's all you're
doing everybody on the right has
problems everybody on the left has
problems why do you keep piling more on
top of each other I don't understand
that you know people need to start
waking up and look at your neighbor and
look at the folks living in Canada in
Mexico and all around us we think there
were some kind of like great nation that
we can do whatever we want and forget
about those guys North forget about
those guys South they're our neighbors
if we're the same and then I say look
across a pond Europe look at Russia
Ukraine all everything we're all
neighbors this is a really small planet
so my whole messages just wake up start
being nice to each other stop piling on
we have enough problems you know I mean
I know I spoke for a long time but no I
just I live this every day because my
heart hurts right now to see where our
country's going and to see where the
world is going we need to do something
people need to wake up and chill out
have some compassion and go talk to your
neighbor in person don't Facebook them
don't Instagram them and all that tweet
and stuff you know walk next door and
talk to your neighbor start speaking
face to face or you're never going to
get true answers you know we got to
start conversing
I like that I like that that's about it
I can I completely agree well that was a
very good introduction
um I I have a bunch of prepared
questions for you but um I thought one
of them is
um what are your views on whether okay
so I'm I don't know that much about uh
gender dysphoria to tell you the truth I
don't either
nobody does like depressed that's real
that's what I'm trying to say is nobody
does
yeah okay otherwise we wouldn't be doing
surgery on these kids you know if we
knew what gender identity disorder was
we really knew what it was we wouldn't
be doing surgery on kids
we'd be digging in there and looking at
the underlying causes we'd looking at
anxiety at depression at a myriad of
other things that could add up to gender
identity disorder we got to look at
childhood trauma we've got to look at
generational trauma is one of the ones
that we keep missing there's there's so
many things so the fact is those
psychologists that think they know
because they went to surgery they don't
know
so if you really want to know what it is
you need to speak to some other folks I
think it's about talk to some
philosophers or maybe some religious
people because at least they're trying
you know
yeah I like that that idea of
generational trauma too that's something
I kind of was like nah that's kind of
hippy-dippy but then I started looking
at my family and and you know with
there's alcoholism on one side and you
know I know my great grandpa was dropped
off on a doorstep when he was a baby and
then these kind of things do modify your
behavior and then you teach your kids
those behaviors that are modified so
there really is something to that
generational trauma 100 I could go into
that one pretty deep because I've passed
on my own generational trauma I had two
boys and unfortunately some of the
things that I've learned to stop doing
you know now I I did some of that to my
to my two boys and oh that's my worst
nightmare yeah I saw you know so I have
a five-year-old girl and I noticed and I
was I was quite ill for most of my life
um I had very very Chris crippling
depression and um arthritis and I
noticed some of the behaviors I did when
she was really little
and and I I tried to stop myself as soon
as I noticed myself doing them and her
mimicking them I was like oh no no no no
I don't want some of these behaviors
passed on I need to get myself sorted
out right now yeah that's awesome you
wrote to Psycho that's awesome
well hopefully I don't know I'm sure I
passed on Plenty of problems but at
least I think I got some under control
yeah
um so what do you think say you have a
kid who's experiencing gender dysphoria
what should a parent do
you do what parents do you love them you
talk to them you have a lot of
conversations and then if there's
conversations that get Beyond you you
find a good counselor you know even
though I'm given a lot of crap to
counselors and all that there's some
amazing counselors out there one of my
professors actually at the University I
was going to is an amazing counselor and
I would go to him every day and he's a
childhood counselor you know he does a
lot with youth and Dr Curtin and uh you
need to find someone like that someone
who's like open-minded and doesn't have
an agenda doesn't have a narrative
doesn't have like he's no push because
it has to be a very open dialogue and
just let let them speak and uh you'll
want to do individual but you're going
to also want to do groups with with your
child because I think that's important
because you should be able to know all
the stuff that's going on and about
because you're with your kid more than
that one hour session with the counselor
so you should kind of know what's going
on so that you can continue when you're
home now it's not you're going to let
your kid be a kid you know but you're
not going to force a kid one way or the
other surgery is definitely not the
answer because this is a lot it's much
more internal than it's external and an
external solution for anyone you know is
going to be an issue and when I talk
about gender identity disorder I'm also
talking about women and men who do the
uh very far out
um gender uh surgeries that they do you
know when they do the math of breast
augmentation or we have guys putting
these huge calves in their legs you know
the guys that have really big upper
bodies but they have chicken legs so
they put they add calves on you don't
think that's gender identity disorder
now the good part is is those gender
identities are in line with their uh
physical sex and so it's easy to cover
up it's easy to hide it's easy everybody
accepts it and the problem in society
right now thanks to the Kardashians and
all the other crap they uh
it's like way over the top so for women
um women and the female uh gender eye
disorder so it's a line it's parallel
what are they doing you know if you look
at those magazines look what the
Kardashians are going and all those
other people they're they're it's almost
uh it's like mimicking you know real
women and you know what I mean and I
think men do the same thing which they
all want to be like Arnold
Schwarzenegger or all the other folks
who are you know way over the top you
know bodybuilders and all that but they
can't do it because physically not
everyone can do that physically not
every woman is going to be you know
looking like a Marilyn Monroe hourglass
figure and everything else it's just not
possible you know we're all different
shapes and sizes and we should be proud
of that whenever they talk about
diversity it just cracks me up that they
miss the whole point of diversity you
know they want diversity but they want
everybody to be the same in their
diversity you know if they wanted to
invite somebody to talk about diversity
in a LGBT TQ environment I would be the
most diverse person that they would ever
meet because I'm transgender I have
gendered Identity Disorder so I'm still
in your group you know and I was a Navy
CEO and I was
surgery and no surgery and detrans all
the other stuff you're not going to find
a more diverse character but they kick
me out they don't want diversity they
want diversity as long as it lines up
with their agenda you know and then when
you start talking about inclusion is a
whole nother thing I don't know if they
really know d e and I if they really
understand what inclusion really means
you know there's a there's a lot of
these little issues that seem to be
exasperating and just going in one
direction towards the same slippery
slope it seems like
everything keeps aiming at the same
thing to get rid of all the whites and
and then we're gone you know that's what
it seems to me I don't get it that's
what they're teaching universities every
time I go to De and I that's ever if
you're not you know if you're white male
and especially that Christian and middle
class or anything else you're not
allowed you're excluded how is that
diversity I don't get that you know I
mean I'm rambling on a whole bunch of
different things but no all of this is
it all adds up together and if we had
enough time
it all comes together it's all the same
stuff
it's taken word to take in labels it's
taking all the stuff and it's changing
them to meet narratives it's changing
everything to meet an agenda rather than
taking a word it means this and it's
like what that word means that well
maybe we need to invent another word or
like even a sports you have uh male and
female sports for for reasons you know
if I was to go in and fight UFC
when I was supposedly transgender and
I'd fought UFC when I was claiming you
know a female which I never really did I
was like being women and being female
was different in the way I saw the whole
thing so if I fought UFC during that
time period when they would have let me
do you think I would have just crushed
everybody I mean I probably would have
gotten beat there's some tough ladies
out there but I I mean the power and the
ability that I would have that
barely any women would ever have because
of the testosterone going through my
body for you know 40 something years you
know and just the the sine use drugs and
the ligament connections just the way
I'm built I would crush all those women
and I just thought that would be unfair
just like ridiculous so I never even
entertained the idea that I would ever
compete against women in anything you
know they even said that I could apply
for uh these special grants and things
these women grants and I was like No And
I said that doesn't even make any sense
you know so I did kind of put myself
whether most people have noticed it or
not I don't mean anybody noticed it but
I had myself in kind of a different
class I did not want to
um
I mean no I did kind of mess up a little
bit where I did encroach a lot on a
women's territory so I wouldn't say I
didn't you know that was a huge mistake
and I admit that but there were
definitely areas that I would never
think to ever cross those lines and
right now all the lines are crossed and
there are no boundaries and now they're
actually changing definitions of words
you know that how does that make sense
who do you think like you said it's part
of a bigger agenda do you think this is
this is coming from something external
or is is this just people making things
crazy within America
within America it's um
for a while I keep pointing to Sweden
and and it's been a couple of years I've
been talking about the Netherlands
Sweden and Scandinavian countries who
were very far in front of this entire
transgender curve and the transgender
surgery curve especially and uh about a
year ago I think I started doing a
really big study and it's called the J
curve and it's in Sweden and it's the
gender surgery or gender identity J
curve and you can look it up Google it
but uh they had this there was the curve
went and it went it shot way up and it
looked like a j I went bam it was a 1500
increase in our teenagers identifying as
transgender or non-binary 1500 increase
does that sound like a popular or fad or
something does that sound like
somebody's pushing it or it's it's like
it became so popular that the wave kind
of picked up a lot of people well that's
what Sweden found out and so Sweden kind
of they didn't put a hall to it but they
said hey we need some studies we need to
figure this out so Sweden reacted the
government freedom and people there they
went up in arms they were like what's
going on this doesn't seem right and
they did the curve now goes way up and
now it goes it starts going way back
down oh wow and who knows where it's
going to go but they corrected it and
the biggest thing I keep talking about
is if somebody has has you know GID and
they have you know they're transgender
and you want to do surgeries and you're
over 18 you're over whatever age you
know rock on you know do your thing and
have a great life and I congratulate you
the thing is if it's teenagers and you
see just 1500 percent you know uptake in
this going on there's a lot of people
getting swept up inside of that tidal
wave and when those folks that are not
tidal wave when they graduate high
school when it's all over and they no
longer have that peer pressure they no
longer have all those hormones running
through bodies and it's all wild you
know high school high school's just yeah
it's one of those times nobody wants to
redo it it's crazy so
all those folks that get swept up in
this tidal wave when the tidal wave is
over when you're done with high school
and you're sitting there 22 years old
and you have a job you start really
thinking
all those folks that got wrapped up in a
tidal wave what's going to happen to
them
and so they keep saying they care about
trans kids they care about trans kids
they keep saying how much they care do
they care about those people they're
getting swept up do they care about the
people that find out that this wasn't
really me because I had boom boom boom
boom they start going down the line of
other things or they had really intense
gender identity disorder because of all
of these reasons or all my friends were
trans so it was just it was easier you
know that's kids that's how kids talk
you know they do
when they start really thinking about it
when they're 22 23 30 years old
what happens to them now for me when I
say I care about the kids I care about
all the kids I care about those kids
that have gender identity disorder
they're gender dysphoria and I care
about the ones I have it really bad that
might end up having to have surgery
later in life I care about them I don't
want you to be healthy I want you to be
happy I also care about the ones that
the transgender Community does not care
about I care about the ones the trans
kids that they say are trans kids I care
about the ones that you do not care
about the ones when they're 22 years old
they found out they made a mistake I
care about them
and those are the ones if you start
looking at the rates of taking your own
lives of everything else that's going on
this is the problem that nobody wants to
talk about and I feel like I'm the only
one talking about this and I know I've
talked when I was on Robbie Starbuck I
was very emotional and I was I was very
very lucky that my fiance Courtney was
there with me because uh she's an
academic and she
she goes right into the academics of it
and I'm very passionate I go yeah and
then she goes dude she just starts going
right through it and so she's you know
magnificent when it comes to that to
just talk me down a little bit and make
me not be so passionate but I do want
you to understand that I I do care about
all those kids who have gender dysphoria
and and want to do surgery later in life
you know all for it you know but follow
the guidelines and right now the
guidelines I've been talking about this
again for like a year is uh the Harry
Benjamin protocols and uh they they
started canceling all the stuff out and
he went to wpath and uh the W path I
said a long time ago it has been
um it's corrupted it's uh it's it's gone
to the point where it's just a it's a
check in a box and then the other part
is that everybody knows how to game
system so they have coaches for
transgender kids now and so if you're a
trans kid and your parents don't agree
with what you're going on they can hide
it and do all the staff and you'll be
assigned a coach you'll be signed an
older transgender person to sit right
there with you and give you the words
now does that sound good what does that
sound like to you I mean that sounds
kind of like
um
I don't know I've known some religions
in the past that used to do that kind of
stuff you know yeah and then you all end
up drinking Kool-Aid you know they don't
last very long because the whole thing
falls apart because it's a house of
cards you know and they're building a
huge house of cards that's worldwide
and uh I don't want the rest of the
world to look at America that we're all
doing this because I think it's a very
very small number of Americans and I
don't want you to look at all the
transgender people the older transgender
people that I know have been calling me
and writing me notes and saying yeah
you're right about this this and this
and this but this is and I'm like well I
was right about a lot I said can you
keep digging and looking more of it I
said yeah yeah we want to
a lot of transgender people the older
transgender people that I know are uh
are a little upset you know I think it's
more of an activist problem I think when
you get these people in there who are
being paid and they're activists and
they have their most of them have good
hearts and they want to help
but there comes a time when they're
activist and I don't know if that's a
word but activizing I don't know when
they're doing it so hardcore and they're
so wrapped out to it and that becomes
their entire identity so their identity
is no longer human their identity is no
longer American their identity probably
isn't even transgender anymore their
identity is an activist and all they're
trying to do is recruit and get their
side of the story out and then make sure
that any other part of the story is as
quiet as possible and for me there's a
guy named Gobles that did that really
well you know I mean it's propaganda and
the lot of stuff that I'm talking about
is uh I can tie it into politics and
religion and all kinds of things all the
failed States and all the failed
religions and all the failed everything
that you see start out with a lot of
good intentions even Cults and uh fiance
Courtney she's a call to expert that's
one of the things she studied and she's
been coaching me through a lot of this
and I'm just like my it blows my mind
when I start seeing the parallels and if
somebody would write a paper on us as a
PhD thesis maybe she should do it but
the um I just I keep finding things that
line up and it's and it's just it's
horrible and uh if you're a kid you have
no chance and uh at least I had a chance
you know when I was a kid you know I
grew up and I was a kid and I hid a lot
of stuff and then I finally started
after I retired and then uh and now I
look back at my life and I still cannot
pinpoint the exact time and I can't
pinpoint any like one event you know I
think it's a it's a it's like the death
of a Thousand Cuts you know it's um it
was just a whole bunch of little things
all adding up and then finally it broke
you know and I just I think that happens
with a lot of folks you know if you're
not taking care of the small things all
those small things will add up to really
big later in life and I think that's the
value of having a good coach or a mentor
or that good counselor I'm talking about
or even if you had a parent or a sibling
or somebody you can speak to we all need
to talk to somebody because none of us
are right none of us know everything you
know we need to go out there and
investigate and have dialogues and speak
and I'm speaking way too much I'm sorry
I think I'm gonna answer most of your
questions no no I just realized I said
well I'm talking too much no no no
that's why you're on here
um I think I think the lack of
communication could easily be
contributing to just mental illness as a
whole I know that if I like during covet
and there have been periods of time
where I've been isolated in my life and
like I don't stay sane for sure like for
sure you need to be able to talk out
loud to somebody about what's going on
around you to make sure it's real I
think well if you if you think about
prisons and you think about like wartime
when we have somebody in A POW Camp or
something or it's like the worst
punishment can give somebody isolation
you know you put them in isolation and
after a while the person's gonna break
you know they're going to give up the
information or they're just going to go
in it really does it affected heavily we
are social creatures you know we have to
have that social you know everything you
know so yeah isolation is terrible
yeah and I I wonder how much you know
especially younger Generations now with
spending a lot of time on Tick Tock and
just being fed you know certain things
through Tick Tock and not hanging out
with their friends or going outside I
don't know what kids do now but I don't
know if they go outside and play in the
streets like they used to like even I
did when I grew up
um that's got to be isolating too even
though you have social media and friends
on social media it's still it's not real
exactly yeah I love what you said to
social media it's 100 isolation if all
you do is look at your phone you're not
with anybody you're with digits you know
yeah we need to go back to an analog
world you know and I've I've been going
around my entire house LEDs everything
and I'm going back to analog I don't
want anything digital in my life if it's
not analog I don't want it you know and
I count that for people too there are
some very digital people out there you
know they run on computer programs you
know that's like there's a book I read
called the uh it's a chimp brain Paradox
and uh most people in this day and age
because of the the society we're living
in they're all digital they're not even
living on a human way and humans are
analog we run an analog everything you
know they're digital they're run on
computer programs it's a yes and no
world for them you know I hate you I
love you and it's not everything it's
it's the same problem
yeah that definitely contributes I like
I worry about that for myself too I have
a podcast so I spend a lot of and I I
have a lot online you know a brand and I
help my dad with his
online I guess you could call it a brand
and so I spend all my time on a computer
but then I I section off periods of the
day because I have a five-year-old so I
section off where I'm like okay gotta
put my phone down
you know I do I don't have them here but
I definitely better I should wear them
more all the time every time you're on a
computer you better do blue blockers
because there's the frequency of the
blue light is coming out of here is very
very dangerous yeah no I can feel it
yeah it's bad so do the blue blockers
when you're on a computer especially if
you're on it every day yeah I should do
that more I have uh I like I changed my
phone cover so my phone kind of takes
away all the blue light so at least I do
that but I used to be better with the
blue blockers awesome
yeah they dropped it I dropped it
um do you have anything to say to kids
who are say I and I feel like this
happens a lot especially in more
probably more liberal areas of the
country if they're having gender
dysphoria and they're in school and
they're being encouraged to do surgery
and told hey you know the suicide risk
is higher but if you do the surgery or
suicide risk will drop do you have
anything to say to kids considering
surgery
um I mean I would say something kind of
funny and this would be pointing more at
the parents would be um
your kids chose a name or what the kid
wants to be called and I mean when I was
a kid what would be like a silly name
that some kid want to be killed when
they were kids you know call me fire
truck you know I'm not saying I want to
be fired or just
Pocahontas get Pocahontas so yeah so
what you should do is have your kids
saying hey let's um let's just tattoo
Pocahontas across your forehead and just
hold have that for a while because
that's what you want to be how to be
Pocahontas let's just tattooed you for a
while but do it like Hannah or something
and then just have like this giant
Pocahontas you know or something cause
your face so everybody sees it every
second and then we'll see what happens
you know and it would be a permanent
tattoo and then you let them know the
permanence of it you know what if you
had a permanent tattoo across your face
with something like just big label so
that every time somebody saw you they
saw that giant labeled across your face
and was it was the only thing they could
really see you know and then see how you
feel see how people treat you see how it
all fits in and then how what do you
feel about that and just the
conversation alone would be you know
well a permanent tattoo across my face
why would I want to do that well I mean
it's the same thing you know it's
something that's very permanent and it's
right there it's in front of everybody
and it's something that's really hard to
change so if you've got like a a giant
tattoo across your face to remove tattoo
it's very painful and it takes a long
time a lot a lot of money and it's the
same thing as that so for me I did get
breast augmentation you know and that
was also just I don't know what happened
and that was another thing I'm trying to
find out what I did wrong as far as me
needing that for me to be fulfilled and
whatever you know intellectual or uh
mental health reason and at the time it
seems right but as I look back on it it
was like I don't know what I did
and then
so
they're doing a permanent
uh surgery to their bodies that they're
not going to change very easily it's
very difficult to change very painful
and some of the changes uh Chloe Cole I
bring her up because she's one of the
only public you know younger transgender
people that she just talked to Dad so
Dad Dad called me yeah Dad called me
today and I said and said oh yeah I
really want to get Chloe Cole out yeah
go who's Chloe Cole and I was like oh
that's interesting I'm talking to Chris
back today so yeah she's an excellent
example and I don't bring up any other
ones but there's there's hundreds and
the thing is is like they're still young
they don't want to be in the news Chloe
is taking a lot of heavy hits and I hope
they don't use her an abuser like they
did me on CNN and she's still very young
and I was an adult when I got used in
kind of that machine of yeah mainstream
media and you know I mean you've been on
enough shows and things that it's a
machine it's entertainment you know and
they're going to use you up as much as
they can hey go on this show I want to
show go on the show and they're doing
that to Chloe and I do hope if Chloe
hears this you know take a take a break
you know I did all those new shows and
if you think you're gonna get something
out of it you're not they're getting
something out of it you know it's not
going to be a money maker unless there's
some way for you to move it into that
but it says news they just want to chew
you up entertainment and then you're
done you know and and I I feel bad that
she's just so young I'm doing that to
her I hope somebody's helping her out
and just talking to her and saying hey
yeah we'll do that one and not that one
start being very selective you know that
would be a good choice but for parents
like I said I was being a little bit
tongue-in-cheek about the tattoo thing
but I moved very serious too when you do
those surgeries it's like something on
your face it's like right there all of
it everybody sees it everybody sees you
you see all them and you have to feel it
all the time every time you look in the
mirror you're gonna feel it now you're
gonna feel it really good you're gonna
love it you know but what happens when
you don't love it you know and then you
can't change it that's what I'm saying
it's just so permanent and so right
there
and the other thing is is they talk
about gender being
um fluid they talk about non-binary they
talk about these 50-something or is it
80 now genders and all this stuff
so why are all the surgeries only binary
and that was something I asked people
all the time it's like well can I assort
it as non-binary well there is not one
so what what's non-binary oh it's
fashion
oh okay so now we understand non-binary
um so I can put on clothing and be
non-binary oh yeah yeah you're good uh
yeah if you're a girl just wear jeans
and a cowboy hat and you're non-binary
well no that doesn't make any sense so
just so much stuff and I know I'm
I'm at the point right now and I think
the whole world is getting really close
to that point well I'm just tired of it
I don't want to talk about this anymore
I want it to be over it's just like the
the end of the fourth quarter and it's a
tie game and it's just everybody's tired
and then everybody's crying about
everything that everybody's dying and
it's like I I don't I don't buy that
you know I buy the thing that somebody's
life is in danger if they're not able to
talk to somebody so if it's a kid that's
in school and they start becoming
transgender at school and then the
parents find out about it the parents
are going to be pretty angry and their
parents are going to say no I mean any
parent would would nay I just got
tricked and my kid comes home and this
is what's going on well let's just hold
the horses stop right here and uh let's
go talk to somebody and then that kid
gets so upset that they move out they
become homeless and then what happens
after that so there's also a lot going
on where I want parents to know
that if your child does this and they do
even do it behind your back it's your
child
you know and you can still talk to him
and you can work this out you know go to
some counseling you know read about the
Harry Benjamin protocols read about a
lot of the other stuff there's a there's
hundreds of books out there that could
be very very educational to people on
both sides of the aisle and uh one of
those books I think was called Born in
the right body uh there's a there's a
bunch of books out there I could I could
probably send you a list of books that
are very very interesting that if you
start reading these stories and these
are actual stories in this one book by a
whole bunch of uh transgender people who
have d-trans or transgender people who
are still trans it's a it's a mix-up of
stories and a lot of women too feminists
and anti-feminists and all kinds of
people so you try to collect the
information from all sides of the story
read some different books don't just
read the one book that you get from you
know that Drag Queens Library you know
that book probably isn't going to be
very two-sided it's going to be very
one-sided book and that's a problem I
don't want all these parents and I don't
want all these kids to only get one side
of the story and that's one of the
biggest reasons it's probably the
biggest reason I even came out and
started speaking out yeah you know
Chloe's doing a great job and I don't do
very many of these because I just want
to have enough of a voice from some of
the uh Elder trans people who have been
there before and I have a little bit of
a name that I just want you to know that
my voice is just backing up Chloe to
make sure that people listen to her and
to make sure that she's taken care of
the way all those other kids need to be
taken care of you know listen to them
find out what's going on find out why
the surgery happened
and who authorized it where it was going
what was the diagnosis and I'll go
through the entire DSM if I have to with
each one of these kids to find out what
was going on you know because they're
missing something something is missing
you know and I I just want to land my
voice right now that I am here I am not
transgender by the ideology that
currently exists I have what they used
to call gender identity disorder and
unfortunately for me it's a cross
identity which causes a lot of issues
they're not problems or challenges it
does help in a few different ways you
know in my fashion sense is fabulous you
know I'm just kidding I just I have to
have some levity here because this stuff
is just so so like it's harsh man
I just there are things that I know
where I'm Different that I do think a
little bit differently I don't think
like a woman but I do think um
and it starts turning those stereotypes
if I start doing that but there are some
things that I do and I act like that
I think would be part of that cross
identity type of a thing and I think if
we start really looking at ourselves as
humans and people start being honest
with ourselves you're gonna find that we
all have a lot of that the only thing is
like maybe I'd let mine affect me a lot
more for whatever reasons you know and
and if you have those guys who are
lifting weights and they have the
chicken legs and they're putting those
giant calves in you know you have
identity disorder you're just lucky it's
parallel with your own you know you know
birth sex you know
I just there's a lot we need to work on
and the only way we're gonna be able to
get through this is for people to start
being honest for people to start being
honest with yourselves honest with your
vocabulary with the words you use and
being precise with those words and into
speaking to each other and in a truthful
manner not your dialogue you're not your
narrative not your agenda where you're
trying to do something for yourself you
know do you think I gain anything from
doing this I the only thing I gain is a
whole bunch of death threats yeah you
know and I'm honest about that I get
death threats I don't make a cent from
doing any of this stuff and I will never
make a sound from any of the stuff
because I think that would be kind of
gross you know I just
I'm gonna live my life and just I'll
give speeches you know I give talks like
your dad does but not his level holy cow
but I do get invited to give speeches at
corporations and I talk about diversity
inclusion I talk about the SEAL Teams I
give them field team stories about
things that I learned like the really
hard way it was like this one time it
was like in the middle of this compound
and we were going after this guy and
there's a baby crib right in the middle
of this like we're fighting and uh I ran
in the middle of it and got this baby
out of the crib and I was like I talk
about that kind of a story and then I
try to relate it that every day you're
walking down the street you have a
chance to save somebody's life I said it
might it's not going to be in a
firefight and it's a baby in in a
country and all the craziness that I had
to deal with but every day if you start
observing you're going to see people in
stress you're going to see people in
trouble and if you just give them a kind
word give them a smile when they go home
that night they might have a little
different outlook on life you know and
that saved a life with a simple smile
you know and I've been talking about
giving people smiles and trying to help
in this little way to save people's
lives for years and years
and I wish people would start doing that
I was I was walking around Costco just
the other day uh doing that
pre-Christmas shopping that was just
chaos but the whole day I knew it was a
super stressful day and Courtney and I
were here also and we were just walking
around and we made it an effort we made
it to effort to greet everyone we saw if
they were you know open at that and we
were greeting people left and right say
Merry Christmas how you doing and just
being funny and joking with everybody
and you wouldn't believe the responses
we got it was like people were stopping
they're shopping and just saying what's
going on hi how you doing you're having
a wonderful day and we just started
talking and it was and that was a simple
thing that we were trying to take one of
the most stressful shopping days just
everybody's panicking and the parking
lot was chaos if people would just slow
down have a smile a short conversation
we'd maybe took 10 extra minutes out of
the entire Costco around 15 minutes out
of our Lives to maybe save a dozen lives
because now they're not stressed they're
not doing this they're not going home
going we couldn't buy that
Chinese rubber duck [ __ ] that we always
wanted you know it's they're out there
running around trying to consume this
crap and it's like everybody's just
frustrated and it's like uh we're just
buying groceries and stuff you know and
everybody's buying all this stuff you
know we need to get all of our regular
stuff that we can't buy on a farm or
grow on a farm yeah but it's just people
need to slow down people can start
having conversations you know stop
buying all that rubber junk you know the
plastic junk that lasts two days and
then you throw it away you know go
analog if you want to really live
but I feel that I feel that I just got
sent I feel like you would like this I
got sent Tallow soap so it's just
saponified Tallow and there's
moisturizer
I'll shoot you over I'll tell you what
the company is it's very nice but it's
the same kind of it reminds me I was
like this is the hippiest thing I've
ever seen but it's kind of nice and
we're so surrounded by it like you said
blue lights and social media and
ideology we try to we try to make all
that stuff ourselves you know we don't
really need to buy that stuff
yeah no that's very true that's very
true
okay let's see
um okay so you've been going on these
podcasts
um who are you getting who are you
getting death threats from that's
horrifying that's got to be stressful
no I mean it's not that stressful I
guess I'm uh I'm kind of used to it you
have experience with stress yeah well
here's this thing I see and that's why I
don't really I'm not really I mean I
know it'll probably happen but I don't
I'm not worried about it you know I at
the same time even when I came out in uh
2014 13 14 whatever it was I uh I got
death threats back then and it was from
the other side I mean I get death
threats from like old military buddies
you know pretty much you know saying you
know if you come anywhere near me I'm
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you oh shoot
I just cursed I'm sorry no no that's
okay oh I said that word earlier God I
just I don't do that normally but um
I uh I just I'm not worried about it
because I wear the armor of God you know
and it and it can be whatever God that
you pray to or you believe in or
whatever I know my God and it's it's the
knowledge that I'm on the right side
it's a knowledge that with everything I
read and all the books that I read and
I've stacks of books that I'm trying to
go through to try to gain some insight
into and I'm a lot the Bible of course
but I'm Christian so of course the Bible
but I read anything else too you know oh
good I don't have to say good
and what are you supposed to say he's
like hey welcome forward hey well we're
the club but
but Christians don't gang up like that
it's just hey this is what I believe and
I think some of the best Christmas I've
ever met we don't really go to church
because most of the churches are the
guys in a Pulpit are collecting too much
money when they have these big houses
and all this other stuff that's not my
kind of church my church is out there in
the Woods by myself you know reading
almost the trees or one or two people
and we go through lessons you know
that's the church that Jesus kept
talking about that we totally missed a
point you know he was brought us that
church he gave it to us you know I don't
apparent I started doing like a sermon I
apologize but um the reason I don't
worry about that and I wear that Armor
of God is because I am I'm held fast to
my beliefs I know my beliefs now I lost
them for a long time I lost my way you
know I felt like it was like you know
in some ways I felt like kind of like
Saul in a way then I felt a little bit
like job and I felt like you know I get
the Technicolor Dreamcoat I went through
all of these things where I had to go
through these really hardships I had to
um figure some things out and I was
tested greatly and uh I passed a lot of
the tests there are some of those tests
that I think I failed that I'm still
working on and I'm trying to do better
and for me to be able to even say that
haters the cat right there the um for
maybe they'll say that that I am held
that fast in my beliefs and I read
through there and is grounded in
Morality as grounded in truth it's
grounded in ethical decisions and all
kinds of things you know and if you
don't have that then you're a ship out
in the ocean with no Rudder you know and
people will make fun of Christians and
will make fun of me reading the Bible
you know because I do I just if I'm
waiting somewhere I always have my
little pocket Bible it's a motorcycle
club Bible has a little motorcycle
analysis Biker's Bible and it's one I
carried around with me for a long time
and then I stopped and I wish I would
have kept doing that because I think
that's what really grounded me but I
just pull it out and start reading it
they know people look at me in a scoff
it's almost like ah Christians it's like
they say with white people oh white
people uh Christians it's like why you
know why can't I have my belief and
that's my belief it's my personal belief
I'm not saying anything to anybody else
because I'm standing there reading the
Bible I'm sitting there in a waiting
room reading the Bible does not in a
year you know they just arrested some
lady it was in Canada she was standing
outside of an abortion oh I saw that no
I don't think that was Canada I think
that was the UK I was UK yeah was he
yeah yeah but she was standing there
just silently not saying a word
and then they said do you know where
you're standing she said yeah this is
abortion clinic well what are you doing
she says I'm just standing here minding
my business and you're like are you
praying she says yes I said well if they
ask me that I pray all the time you know
I pray with every breath I take you know
and if you work on um there's this
breathing technique this is uh that uh
these deep air breathers and it's a
really neat thing but if you think about
uh the name of God and um in the old
Judean way with Yahweh Every Breath You
Take is speaking the word of God Yahweh
when you're breathing you're saying the
words of God oh that's that's on purpose
oh I haven't heard that before that's
cool so yeah and so I purposely breathe
the name of God with every breath I take
you know and and you're going to tell me
that now if I go anywhere near an
abortion clinic and I'm breathing
they're gonna arrest me you know come on
the person was just standing there what
are they doing not threatening me
anybody not talking to anybody not doing
it just standing there so how far are
they going to push this
to ask the question I have now I do
think that that's the danger you know
and that's the danger to themselves so
this entire movement that's pushing so
hard they're going to push it so hard
and it's going to go so far that there's
going to be backlash and the backlash is
going to be as as much a probably even
more brutal than what you're doing to
everyone right now and so and I'm not
it's not a threat it is it's just it's
not even a warning it's just a study of
history and when I study history you see
it all the time you know you see that
the oppressed become the oppressors
and if you have a whole group of people
right now that are policing language
that they're arresting people for
standing around that they're arresting
people because they use the wrong
pronoun
you know who's being oppressed that
every corporation around the world every
Fortune 100 company every Fortune 500
company every company around the earth
has a rainbow flag and has this and I
raise them on the flagpoles and they're
having parades and everything
I don't see that for Christians you know
I don't see that for a lot of groups of
people you know so you're not oppressed
I really wish that they would stop
saying they're oppressed because they
can do everything that anyone can do do
you think to your oppression or do you
think the violence that's happening is
caused because you have drag queens
dancing half-naked in front of young
kids
do you think your impression is
happening because you have you know
young kids like Chloe call
who had a double mastectomy at like 15
or 16 years old and there's a there's
the youngest case I've ever heard of
which I'll send well I can't send you
the data but it was 10 years old
you know
how are you doing surgery on a 10 year
old so you know how how do you what do
you think this yeah what do you think
the steps are that
allows surgery to happen with kids under
say 16.
like what are they diagnosed with how is
that like a 10 year old you said even a
14 year old like what happens do they
say that I'm in such psychological
torment that this is the only thing
that's going to fix me
that what are you it's a tactic that
have been used and I've been using it
for a long time that uh he'll tell the
parent
you can have uh live son or a dead
daughter and that would be for like a
trans and and the the majority of this
movement really going on right now are
girls our little girls and so they say
you can have a dead little girl or a
live trans boy
and that's the choice they're given and
that's a false choice you know I mean
talk about
God it's a logic trap of it's a it's a
classic logic trap you know it just
doesn't make any sense it's not true but
that's a choice if you have a PHD
psychologist or a doctor or somebody
else talking to a parent and the parents
aren't trained and the parents don't
know and the parents love their kid and
their parents want their kid to be happy
and alive if you're giving that choice
as a parent and you don't know
what are you gonna do you know and then
the kids
they don't really know
what did you know when you were 12 years
old what'd you know when you're 15 all
of you parents out there all of you
doctors all you adults
look back when you're 15. what were you
doing
geez if I told you what I was doing we
were out there riding pigs and being
idiots and building rafts and it was
like
you were kids we didn't know
so to do this it's just it's appalling
that this has gone this far and I keep
saying the same thing and I know if you
listen to all the words I said if
somebody actually listens to all this
they're going to be able to pick this
apart and there's all kinds of hate you
can pick out little pieces and make me
sound really horrible
but I love all those kids I want them to
be happy I in the in a
in a grand scheme of things the the time
you're talking about for them during
that two or three years of junior high
and going into high school or whatever
when you're going through all that we
all went through it we all had those
thoughts we all had it it's just wild
but we have to slow them down you know
they're kids
yeah I don't think my brain grew in like
I think I could remember a switch when I
was about 22 to 23. like it wasn't even
18. it was 22 to 23 and I can remember
thinking
oh I I can just think long term now or I
understand the repercussions of my
actions right because I didn't
understand I just didn't have the
thought of repercussions of my actions
not really
um and then sometimes between the age of
22 and 23 it's switched over and it's
like oh okay I think my brain just fully
grew in
well I mean there's there's a whole
bunch of tests that you do in Psychology
and one of the classic Taps is a
peekaboo test so there's an age and I
think it's four years old is when they
get rid of that one thing it's their
permanence and so you know when you put
your peekaboo and that when you cover
your eyes up the kids are like they're
like really where'd you go because they
don't and if you put an object behind
something and say where is it now if
they don't see it it's not there I think
that lasts to like four years old and
then there's a whole another series of
things and if you study human
development it does it's all these
little things are happening with your
brain and how it's developing you know
and so you're gonna have a kid that's
still kind of playing peekaboo and then
start doing surgery on them you know
it's just that's what they're talking
about you know it's just it's utterly
ridiculous the psychological Community I
hold him responsible they could have
stopped this you know and I also hold
the um leadership within the lgbtq
community
um there's a ton of things I could talk
about I could talk about the double x
male syndrome which I think they
actually erased it out of the books
um it used to be a lot of data at um
Darren what was that there was a
hospital uh
Dan I'm sorry I can't remember there was
a there was a huge study and it was all
about the double x male syndrome and
some other things but um
it would have it would have made it
scientific what is that
well it has to do with uh phenotypes and
then genotypes and then you have to do
that and then when you start going into
all of this it uh it it gets very
confusing but it especially if that's a
crossing and so and this does cross it's
very common and so we have the genotype
crossing the phenotype then you have to
look at things differently and it's
actually chemical and it's how they it's
it's everything you know and it's
actually a scientific thing to take a
study but they don't want it to be
science because it's science it's
provable and then it's only that person
because here it is provable and so they
don't get to have the kind of
wishy-washy feeling thing you know
because right now this entire movement
everything is based on feelings you know
if you take almost the entire
um lgbtq Community IA I don't know how
many more letters they've added I think
they just added three or four more
letters
um they have the red thing on there for
sex workers now they're they're talking
about adding um Maps minor Attractive
people and a bunch of other stuff for
and that's the problem too is I just
keep expanding it so the expansion of
this thing is going to who knows where
but um this
I don't know you know but these are
things that if it's only a feeling and
that makes me part of this group it
makes me popular I'm no longer isolated
I'm no longer picked on because now I
have a powerful group you know and
everybody wants to be part of that team
you know it's either you want to be part
of the football team if you're a boy the
soccer team uh the weightlifters the
maybe the pot smokers the band guys you
want to be part of one of those groups
if you're all by yourself it's really
hard to survive you know and so you want
to join a group and if you're that
person that's just kind of you fit in
there you're just going to join that
group you know that's my group and then
you're now just sad
and so I people just need to start
studying and and I can go into that the
genotypes phenotypes I think Courtney
could do it way better than I could
because she also studied this and she
gives me a clue on some of the stuff and
I study it and then I get I know about
it but I'm not going to dig in as deep
as an expert could but I bet you there's
a lot of folks out there right now that
want to look it up and I hope you do you
know and I want you to look at the
science of it rather than the feeling of
it you know if all it took was a feeling
for me to be a Navy SEAL to him
what would that make us you know I
couldn't become a Navy CEO because I
felt like a Navy SEAL you know it
doesn't work that way you know and
nothing in life works that way if I just
feel like yeah you know nothing in life
that works out the entire base of the
entire transgender and especially
non-binary is just based on feelings and
fashion you know and and I fell in that
trap you know I think a lot of women are
falling in that trap and I hope people
start opening their eyes open look at
that it's a trap
well hopefully you talking about it
helps some people I know um
I know from like having
an autoimmune disorder myself I thought
it was very painful and I lost a lot of
my life to that and I felt like the only
way that I could make up for that
without being extremely angry mostly at
the medical community was to stop other
people from going through the same thing
so if I could help other people avoid
that then I could kind of like forgive
the medical community yeah for now I'm
very familiar with autoimmune diseases
yeah
do you are you suffering from anything
uh not me
I think a very close uh okay it's okay
Courtney was walking through this end
Courtney has an autoimmune uh disease
alopecia Universal Alice
oh my gosh yeah
um you should well we don't have to get
this into this on the podcast but she
should give the diet I'm on a go
it's not a quack diet it's what put my
myself into remission and my dad my dad
had alopecia
um he had alopecia yeah he had alopecia
it it went away though he had it in his
30s it went away and then he had
psoriasis and then gum disease and
um just various autoimmune symptoms but
I I've known people with alopecia have
put themselves into remission talk about
somebody who has who has lived a life if
you have alopecia Universal house you
lose all your hair and uh I think it
happened to her she was 14 or 15 years
old so going right through the middle of
like the most turmoil like
and uh talk about somebody who's strong
though somebody who's stronger spirit
and character and everything else like
live a life like that when you're a kid
like that and she's had it the whole
time now so decades and decades and just
everything and you know when you have
something like that a lot of other
things happen so and like I said
everyone suffers you know just stop a
lot you know a lot
yeah it's amazing how much people can
suffer and and you don't know they just
show up and keep doing their people
thing but yeah I like that trying to
make people smile if you want to have a
great conversation you know get Courtney
back on here because she the women in
gender studies and the cult stuff and
and her alipation a bunch of other stuff
she just has so much that she'd offer
that I think you'd get a real kick out
of oh that sounds like fun why why did
you decide to detransition
um was there something that happened
now there was there was nothing well
part of it was I sort of loved myself
I started really digging in and
understanding the concept Understanding
Psychology like I said I started going
for a master's degree in mental health
counseling and I learned so much and
there's no way that anybody could learn
what you need to know about psychology
or counseling or mental health or
anything if you don't take those courses
and barely anybody can take all those
courses you know or read all those books
and really dig into it so and that's why
we have to rely on experts but uh I
didn't have that chance at the at the VA
the um the mental health counseling and
and psychology departments at the VA are
just it's not good and so if you're
looking for help and for me I'm living
on my retirement and I don't have a lot
so I'm not going to be able to go hire
somebody or do anything you know so I
just started doing it myself and that's
one of the big reasons why I started
going into the course good for you I
wanted to heal myself you know I was
tired of everything just seemed bad I
had pretty bad PTSD the traumatic brain
injury from a lot of explosions and then
um I had other stuff going on I also had
a opioid issue for a while there because
they're pushing those things out of so
bad and once you start doing them you do
enough of them that you're going to get
stuck you know it's a it's it's one of
those
it's one of those things that if you if
you take some of it you keep doing it
you're gonna get stuck you're down you
know it's a terrible terrible drug
so
I had to heal myself and then so I was
doing that right in the middle of that I
met Courtney and uh for the first time
in my life I truly fell in love I uh I
found someone who loved me and I loved
her like 100 like holy it was um
I never had that before you know and
I'll tell people who I was with before
that I love them you know but it wasn't
it wasn't the same it wasn't like that
there was something missing and I think
what was missing was that I wasn't
healed myself what was missing that I
didn't love myself you know and you
can't love yourself how you'd expect to
love somebody else
and so in my healing through me going
through these schools and all these
courses and reading all these books and
then also me meeting you know starting
to love myself and meeting someone else
who was actually truly able to fall in
love with you know really started
clicking in and so that's been a couple
of years now and then um
if anybody noticed I've been wearing
flannel shirts all summer and 90 degree
weather because I was trying to cover
myself up and just kind of hide and
haven't worn makeup for a long time you
know or anything you know and then I
like I was just at the point where it
was like a purge like beyond belief it
was like if anything even looked even
slightly feminine I would just throw it
away or burn it because I just it didn't
disgust me but it made me remember my
old self who was just it was wrong you
know it made me remember the pitfalls I
fell into about the self-hatred and the
self-loathing you know it made me fall
in a pitfall about about uh esteem you
know lack of esteem or even ego comes
into it where uh you have to be pretty
egotistical to think that you could do
something better than somebody was born
the way they were born you know what I'm
saying so there's all these things that
had overcome and I did that uh slowly
with Courtney's how I was able to do it
you know much faster than I probably
could have on my own I I probably
couldn't ever completed on my own
because it's very arduous you know it's
it's you
looking deep inside of yourself and like
really asking yourself the hard
questions like all the questions you've
asked me you're all like yeah you know I
asked myself some really hard questions
you know questions I probably could
never repeat on the air you know I might
in person if it's just personal but the
um there's things that you have to dig
through and really really dig and then
you will start learning where you are
and you'll start learning who you are
and then you'll start falling in love
with yourself you know and I'm not
saying that it's it sounds weird but
the way I see it is if I can look in a
mirror when I wake up in the morning and
this is another thing I talk about when
I'm giving speeches is that how many of
you are looking at me or when you're
brushing your teeth or shaving or
whatever putting on your makeup you
don't actually really look at yourself
and just say hey you're a great person I
love you
how many people do that you know I can
nobody you know I wasn't able to do that
for a long time
can you do that now myself I do that now
all the time wow I say thank you to
myself you know I blast myself I say hey
I'm grateful I'm blessed you know I'm
doing great you know if I see a mirror
say hey you're cool you know
it just it's a we have to talk positive
of ourselves we have to start seeing
ourselves as good people as a as a
beautiful person as a loving person and
love yourself if you don't have
gratitude for yourself you know you're
you're not going to get very far you
know and so and that was all the things
I had to learn on my own and then
finally with help you know and and I'm
grateful that I had somebody could help
me like that I think a lot of people are
missing that
but if you just like when we're walking
around Costco I talked about a little
earlier we were walking around just
being friendly and just talking to
people and it was like we just made a
whole bunch of friends like in one day
just walking around talking to people
you know if you change your attitude you
might find people changing attitude back
towards you you know and I think that's
probably a really big lesson for a lot
of folks that have that self-loathing or
have that doubt about themselves or they
have a self-esteem problem you know you
have to start with yourself first you
know everyone's going to look at you the
way you look at yourself
so a chance the way you look at yourself
looking at mirror and tell yourself how
cool you are or how beautiful you are
how much you love yourself and then
that's going to affect you it's gonna
it's gonna stick on you and now when you
walk out the front door you're gonna
find people treating you you differently
and when that starts happening your
outlook is going to change and your life
will change
Chris back you are a beautiful person
that was that was really nice no that
was really nice it's like I don't talk
to I talk to a lot of people but I don't
talk to many people that are just
I don't like the word nice exactly uh
it's kind of I think it's kind of empty
but like kind
just looking to make thank you you know
limit suffering everywhere because
people are already suffer enough there
doesn't need to be any added suffering
that was really nice
um can I can I direct anybody anywhere
do you have social media do you want
them to go read something
I want I want everybody to look at the
data in Sweden
um the gender J curve you can type in
any of those things and it's going to
come up and you'll see some studies from
Pink news but who writes pink news
you'll see some studies from a lot of
places that poo poo the dad and say it's
all wrong but look at who wrote those
things and then look at some of the
scientific journals and look at some of
the and the same thing goes the other
way I can say look at a bunch of the
Christian articles about transgender
stuff and you're gonna see the same
thing there's propaganda from both sides
I'm not saying that Christians are being
propaganda but I am saying that there is
propaganda I want you to be aware of
propaganda so what you have to do is you
have to research it on your own you know
look that up you know and look up the um
the double x male syndrome look up uh
gender dysphoria gender identity
disorder rather than transgender you
know and just open your minds you know I
don't I'm fine you know I'm gonna be
okay I don't want anybody to follow me
or doing anything or I don't I don't it
doesn't matter if you want to follow
somebody follow Chloe call you know I
think she's doing a really good job and
she's incredibly Brave you know and I
want her to do well she's had a really
rough life and uh I want her to do
really well from now you know I want her
to she always talks about you know
meeting someone and possibly having a
family and you know bless her you know
and I hope she finds that kind of
happiness
you know that's all I want people to do
is
it's almost like to pay it forward thing
you know but don't give me anything you
know accept your death threats if you
really need to you know but um don't and
even that I just answer them I say hey
thanks a lot you know I get a lot of
those that's the most infuriating
response you could give them but it's um
not even do that to inferior I'm just
like hey you know at least they're
getting anger out I want them to get to
anger out of me if they have to kill
somebody please do it you know come on
because I don't want them to do it to
Chloe I don't want them to do it to
these kids or somebody that doesn't
deserve it you know and I've already
been through the war and I've already I
have a lot of scars you know and um
all right doesn't matter to me you know
but Chloe doesn't deserve that and all
those kids don't deserve that so if you
want to do something you know smile at
somebody give some kind words you know
and just be nice you know and look at it
from both sides please
all of y'all on the right and the left
look at both sides
you know don't believe the propaganda I
don't care who you're listening to on
both sides you're both listening to
propaganda
you know just look at both sides and see
what's going on for real
and that's that's about it
that sounds good thank you very much for
joining me yeah thank you it was
wonderful
[Music]